Joey is made out of three main materials
he's made out of a wicker / / the frame
to give the shape aluminum is the actual
frame which gives rigidity for the
actors to strap into her the puppeteers
and then he's got mesh which makes him
look full it also allows the actors to
be able to see out a little bit but when
it's lit you can't see right through it
which is a very nice composition of the
the art of it joey is built over a
fairly long course of time at handspring
puppet Factory which is in South Africa
and so they're all built and shipped
over here and I believe they start with
the aluminum frame and then they start
just wrapping the the cane around and
getting the forms that they want so
every horse is actually different they
don't they don't build them on a form
they don't Bend each each piece
specifically it's just hand done hand
wrap they wrap little bits of string
around to hold everything in place and
then just glue over the string for the
most part Joey stays as a whole he he
also travels as a whole when we move him
we you know we travel him we get him all
set up and nice and safe and secure and
and he travels all in one piece as well
so we never really take Joey apart
each actor has kind of a physical
movement apart that they carry as well
as a as a like emotional movement but
that can also be something that's
physical so for instance the head
actually controls where the head points
but he also moves the ears the heart
position has the two different movements
he actually curls the feet as well as
actually holding heart but his emotion
is to breathe with the horse and the
hind moves the rear feet and flicks the
rear tail it's a balance that you're
having between whether you're in control
of Joey or Joey is controlling all of us
it's not so much of buttons and levers
that we're pulling but our whole body is
breathing together and integrating to
make the horse seem alive the puppet is
is actually quite simple from just a
basic operational perspective but it's
the it's the life that we have to infuse
the puppet with that sort of makes it
look more complicated and fluid there is
the kind of constant direction that no
matter what's happening on stage we must
always be a living breathing course so
our choreography will be get from point
A to point B but the way we get from
point A to point B will change every
night and more importantly than anything
we need to react to what's happening
around us as a horse would
you